Unusual breaking news that could also
benefit many immigrants in the United States.
The ice immigration agency has just announced that they
will soon have to release between 4,000 and 6,000
immigrants who are currently being held in detention centers.
That's right my people,
you listened well and I explain what's going on.
.
Every year,
the ice immigration agency receives a budget from the
federal government and with this budget they can arrest,
imprison and deport immigrants But this agency is running out of money
and needs more And although a few days ago there was a proposal in the
House of Representatives to give more money to several federal agencies,
including ice.
The Republicans blocked this proposal for political reasons,
so now the ice agency is running out of money and the only solution they have
to save a little is to release thousands of undocumented immigrants who are
currently detained in detention centers and
instead of being deported immediately,
these immigrants will be able to stay with their
families and fight their immigration case in freedom.
So if you have a family member incarcerated
for immigration here in the United States,
you may well be released soon.
Well my people there we will see what happens Let me know what
you think and as always remember anything I will keep you informed.